who does who does which more do women
lie about their body counts more often
than men lie about their jobs women have
jobs to lie about can we speak on the
fact that some men are making things no
men make more than women maybe maybe the
men you deal with them I was talking
about passing me as a whole like
generalization like as men sometimes
they do have like you know like you
would say like paid like good work and
paying jobs I was in the council with I
don't know 100 000 more than women yeah
men do that because they need to
upholders they took but in in a lot of
men's minds they must be the home
bringer right but my point is like who
lies about which more